begins with a sense of what it should be
like beautiful accomplished elegant
perfect and it is so exciting you wake
up bounce out of bed full of hope and
energy and you settle down to work in
your mind's eye you have such a vivid
idea of what you want your masterpiece
to be like you work toil harder than
even you could have envisioned and you
take a step back from what you've done
and realize things aren't the way you'd
hoped let's put it more brutally it's
terrible and you're disgusted by what
you've achieved and the only thing you
can think about is the terrible gap
between what you wanted to do and what
you've actually done and it seems your
taste is well ahead of your abilities
you run away in distress maybe into the
arms of someone who loves you
or perhaps you choose to sit alone where
you contemplate your own profound
mediocrity look at you
you're no better than that little guy at
least he works hard you're so sad you've
gone back to bed
problem is this is too easy
despair is cheap the first rule of
anything creative forgive yourself for
the horror of the first rounds don't
hurry
do a little bit every day keep a
timetable and stick to it work without
hope or despair and you work like this
for days months years even decades and
eventually one day your talents will
catch up with your taste and you'll have
done something in line with your
expectations you might even be a little
proud of yourself and who knows maybe
the rest of the world will be a little
bit too so just keep going
[Music]
you